Here we have a narration
which was collected by al-Hafidh al-Imam
Muslim in his authentic compilation on
the authority of Aisha.
She narrates to us that the messenger of
Allah
said,
"The angels were created from light.
And the jinn, or the jinni, were created
from the edge and transparent part
of the end of a flame.
And Adam was created from that which was
described to you, meaning in the Quran."
This is he was created from
dust, he was created from mud, he was
created from all those descriptions. Not
only was
the essence of his creation described to
us in the Quran, but also the various
stages that that essence went through
before his soul was placed into his body
and he became a fully formed thinking
human being.
So, this narration is quite interesting.
Because there are many creatures
in the earth, correct? So many.
Why is it
that our prophet, our messenger,
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, finds it
relevant
to describe to us
these three creatures? Out of all these
creatures that exist.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
wayakhluqu
[Arabic recitation]
Wal khayla wal bighala wal hamira
And so, Allah tells us
in many verses that
He has created many, many, many
creatures and most of which we are
probably unaware of.
However,
the prophet, sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
found it fit and found it necessary
to
tell us this information and mention
these three creatures together: the
human,
the jinn, and the angels.
Why is that? What do these three
creatures have in common?
Free will?
Very good. These three creatures all
have in common free will.
Correct?
Now, here's a question.
Is it possible that there are creatures
that Allah has created
that have free will outside of these
three creatures that we don't know of?
Is this the be-all end-all only creation
of Allah that he has ever created or
ever will create?
What's the answer, Yakhwan? Huh?
He is the creator. He has always been
the creator.
There could be
thousands, hundreds, million, billions
of creation before us and billions to
follow, right?
Into infinity, something beyond our
scope of understanding. However, the
question is,
could there be creatures out there that
have free will outside of these three
creatures?
If you said yes,
you're wrong. And if you said no, you're
[Arabic recitation]
don't have knowledge of that. We don't
know. Is it possible? Yes. Is it
certain? No.
However, of our creation, of this
creation, of what we are conscious of,
these three creatures have free will.
The humankind, the jinnkind, and the
angels.
Now,
why is the prophet telling us this?
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Well, he's telling us this because these
three creatures
all interact with the human being.
We need to know this, right? We need to
know of the existence of the jinn.
If the jinn did not exist, or excuse me,
if the jinn if we were not told about
the existence of the jinn,
would we ever know that they existed for
sure?
No.
meaning even a shaytan al
rajeem, our greatest enemy,
if Allah had not told us about him, we
wouldn't know about him. Correct? That's
how lost we are as human beings.
And so,
these three are being told to us by the
messenger of Allah because these three
creatures overlap.
They overlap. They interact with each
other.
The angels interact with the jinn, the
angels interact with the humans, the
humans interact with the jinn, the jinn
interacts with the angels, the the
angels interact with the human beings.
Correct? So, it becomes necessary for us
to know of these three
types of creatures that have free will.
The common trait amongst them is that
they have free will, all three of these
creatures, and we are told about them
because we will interact with them at
one point or another in our existence in
some way.
So, this here
means something very important. Our
alien's going to come from another
planet
and land on the White House lawn
and say, "Take me to your leader."
And they are a higher evolved species of
creatures,
and their technology is far more
advanced than our technology, and blah
blah blah blah blah. The these creatures
that have free will, that are not human
beings, they are not jinn, and they are
not angels.
Are these
this type of creature going to ever
cross humanity's path? What's the
answer?
No.
This narration and other narrations like
it prove that.
Because if this were to happen
and our prophet did not make any mention
of it, there's no mention of it in the
Quran, no mention of it in the sunnah
anywhere, this would shake the belief of
the Muslimin.
This is necessary information
for us to know so that the world of the
unseen, whatever of it
we are going to interact with, we know
about it before it comes, we expect it.
There's no surprises for a shaytan to
use to say, "See, if he really was a
prophet, if the Quran really was the
words of Allah, then you would have
known about this. It wouldn't have
caught you by surprise."
So, there won't be any
aliens landing on the White House lawn.
ET will not be riding through the
streets in the front basket of
bicycles, our youth's bicycles, okay?
Yajooj and Majooj are not
some kind of
fourth type of creature that they're
either a small
as they're so tiny in some stories, in
some fabrications, they're so tiny
that they'll enter into the boot of a
human being and think that it's a
mansion.
And in other narrations, they're so huge
that their ears are so big that they lay
one ear down, they lay down on top of it
a a bed, and then they cover
up with the other ear.
Okay? These
are all silly stories
of
the creatures
that
are made up either fables of previous
nations, nations of idolatry,
fables of a shaytan,
any creature
that interacts or overlaps with the
human being
or the jinn
for that matter,
that will cross paths with us from now
until the day of judgment,
if they have free will,
they will be one of these three
creatures.
Be they human beings, jinn, or angels.
There will not be a fourth, an unknown
type that has free will.
Animals, sure. Creatures that exist
outside of this creation that have free
will that we don't know of, but we will
never come in contact with, sure.
Perhaps.
But of what concerns us, these are the
only three creatures that Allah has
chosen
to endow with
free will, to endow with that higher
intelligence, to endow with the freedom
of choice.
Now, how they use that free will is very
different between the humans, the jinn,
and the angels.
But there won't be any ETs arriving,
there won't be any UFOs coming,
and this will either be anything, any
creature
that arrives or
you know, presents itself will be one of
these three types of creatures.
Otherwise, this narration has no
meaning.
It has no relevance.
What is the point of it?
This is
how the scholars of Islam have
understood these types of narrations
because our prophet
came to guide us and leave no doubt
that will take us off of the path.
Anything that could
come out and blindside us, he told us of
it in order that our path to paradise
will be clear and the only kind of
person that will not get to paradise is
someone who made the conscious choice
not to go.
So, now
So,
[Arabic recitation]